I've been quite obsessed with girdles
incompleteness theorem for many years
because it kind of places this
extraordinary limitation on what we
might be able to know in mathematics in
fact it's quite an unnerving theorem
because at its heart it says there might
be conjectures out there about numbers
for example something like Goldbach's
conjecture you might actually be true so
it might be true that every even number
is the sum of two primes but maybe
within the axiomatic system we have for
mathematics there isn't a proof of that
the real worry is what if there's a true
statement that I'm working away on which
actually doesn't have a proof now this
is a big kind of revelation for
mathematics because I think ever since
the ancient Greeks we believed that any
true statement about mathematics will
have a proof we might be quite difficult
to find like Fermat's Last Theorem took
three hundred and fifty years to before
my colleague in Oxford Andrew Wiles
found the proof but I think we all have
this kind of feeling like well surely
every true statement has a proof but
girdle shows that actually there's a gap
between truth and proof
I wrote it down here because it'sit's
quite cute so it's one of these cards
the statement on the other side of this
card is false
so let's suppose that's true so it means
that the explained one on the other side
of the card is false so we turn it over
and then it says the statement on the
other side of this card is true
well that's meant to be false so it
means the one on the other side is also
false oh but we suppose that that was
true so that's false so the other side
is true which means that and you get
into this kind of infinite loop verbal
paradoxes are fine because you don't
expect every verbal sentence to have a
truth value to it but then when I went
up to university I realized that
mathematics you can't have those yet
when I took this course on mathematical
logic and we learned about girdle's
incompleteness theorem he used this kind
of self referential statement to really
undermine our belief that all true
statements could be proved
there was a feeling like we should be
able to prove that mathematics is
something called consistent that
mathematics won't give rise to
contradictions this have been kind of
inspired by certain kind of little
paradoxes that people like Bertrand
Russell had come up with people might
have come across this idea of the set of
all sets that don't contain themselves
as members and then you the challenges
well is that set in this set or not
actually a really nice kind of version
of this is another sort of mathematical
kind of verbal paradox is all those
numbers that can be defined in less than
20 words so for example 1729 which is
the taxicab number that Ramanujan and
Hardy talked about you can define that
in less than 20 words it's the smallest
number which is the sum of two cubes in
two different ways so that less than 20
words so then you define the following
number then the smallest number which
cannot be defined in less than 20 words
now I think if you count add up I've
just defined that number in less than 20
words and you go well that's a bit
worrying because surely that is a sort
of kind of number we might define the
smallest number which has a certain
property so there was a real feeling
that these paradoxes these set theoretic
paradoxes were beginning to be a real
challenge to mathematics at the turn of
the 20th century and David Hilbert one
of his big problems that he challenged
mathematics with in the 20th 20th
century he's 23 big on unsolved problems
the second one was to prove that
mathematics was in fact consistent and
included in that was that every true
statement should be provable but what a
shock he got actually 30 years later
along comes this Austrian logician Kirk
girdle who blows this idea that we can
prove math is consistent out of the
water and shows there are true
statements which can't be proved within
any mathematical system
how does mathematics work we set down
things we called axioms which are the
kind of things we believe are the way
numbers geometry works so for example if
I take six and I add seven to that I
don't think it's going to be different
from taking seven and adding things to
that that seems so blindingly obvious
and that's one of the axioms of the way
numbers work so maybe somewhere out
there that posed wrong but I don't
really care I'm interested in a
mathematics where that is true of all
numbers and I have rules which allow me
to make deductions from those axioms and
that's how mathematics works each time
we make these logical deductions we
expand the conclusions from these axioms
we can add new axioms if we feel like
you know what we haven't actually
captured the whole of mathematics and
that was somehow the the mission was we
want to have a set of axioms which are
strong enough and that we believe are
basic about numbers from which we can
deduce all through statements that we
will have a proof and so there was a
feeling like well yeah well maybe we
haven't got all of the axioms and if we
got a true statement which can't be
proved we could add that as a new axiom
and it will expand what we can prove
within mathematics so this is very
important for girdle because we are
trying to prove that there will be a set
of axioms from which we can deduce all
truths of mathematics
good or did something very clever
because he cooked up a way of allowing
mathematics to talk about itself so what
he produced was the thing we now called
the girdle coding so he showed that any
statement about numbers has its own
particular code number in fact use prime
numbers in order to make this coding so
every statement amount mathematics could
be turned into a number so for example
the axioms of mathematics from which we
are trying to make all of our deductions
they would have code numbers and true
statements about mathematics so for
example fermat's last theorem for
example will have a code number also
false statements like 17 is an even
number will have a code number this is
what these criminals look like okay
there are obviously whoppers the apps
they're absolutely huge but it's a
unique coding so every code number can
be worked backwards into a statement not
every number will have a meaningful
mathematical statement but it's more
interesting the other way every
mathematical statement will have a
unique number associated with it how
most even a computer has a zero isn't
very good so if I'm typing away and I
write the name girdle that be changed
into ASCII code it will have a number
associated with it so good will cook
this up but why is that useful because
you can now actually talk about proof in
mathematics using these numbers so you
can start to talk about mathematics
using mathematics so for example you
might want to know well is this
particular statement provable from the
axioms that I'm going to completely
simplify this but it'll give you the
feel for it essentially it's a bit like
saying any statement whose a code number
is divisible by the code number of the
axioms will be provable from the axioms
that's an incredible simplification but
it's good because it means now we can
talk about proof within opening up
mathematically to say that something is
provable is to say for example that it's
code number must be divisible by the
axioms
so now girdle challenges you with the
following statement this statement
cannot be proved from the axioms that we
have for our system of mathematics so
this is actually something that has a
code number we can talk about proof
using numbers so so this will be a
statement that can be changed into a
mathematical equation now this means
because it's an equation in mathematics
it's either true or its false so let's
start by saying that the statement is
false that means that this statement is
provable from the axioms is true but a
provable statement must be true so now
we've started with something which we
assumed was false and now we've deduced
that it's true so we've got a
contradiction and we're assuming that
mathematics is consistent so we can't
have contradictions this is important so
that means it can't be false this means
it must be true because a mathematical
statement is either true or false it's
not like these linguistic paradoxes
which just don't have a truth value it
is an equation of mathematics it's
either true or is false we've just shown
if it's false but that leads to a
contradiction this means that this
statement must be true ah great we've
got a true statement but let's now
reinterpret what it says it says this
statement cannot be proved from the
axioms we have now got a true statement
which cannot be proved true from the
axioms of mathematics and that's exactly
what girdle wanted he's now got a
statement of mathematics which is true
but cannot be proved and you go well
hold on how do we actually prove that
was true we just proved it's true and
it's very important to articulate what
we have done is within a system of
mathematics with certain axioms we found
a true statement within there which
can't be true proved true within that
system we've proved it's true by working
outside the system and looking in
because we can now add that as an axiom
it's a true statement so it won't make
something which is consistent
inconsistent
so we could add that as an axiom and you
say well now we've got to prove because
it's just an axiom it's one of these
kind of infinite regresses girdle says
that's not going to help you because I
can still cook up within this new system
another statement which is true but
unprovable so it's a sort of infinite
regress thing that it says that have no
matter how much you expand mathematics
adding axioms they will always be
missing something a little bit like if
you remember the proof that there are
infinitely many Prime's you say suppose
there are finitely many Prime's then you
prove that there's some prime is missing
from that list and you say well I'll add
those and you CLE just keeps playing the
same trick well that's still not good
enough because there are still some
things missing girdle has a similar kind
of field to it that you might try and
expand your mathematics to add that as
an axiom but that won't help because we
can keep on playing the same game it
feels like though this problem is just
restricted to this in a self-referential
corner like it doesn't feel like this
puts go back out of reach and other
things that are each it's just this one
little game you can play with
referencing to itself
this was mathematicians hope they're
okay there's some weird logical
gajillion sentences which who really
cares about because they don't really
have much mathematical content and I
think people just hoped that things like
Goldbach would not be one of these but
that hope was really blown away in 1977
mathematicians came up with some
statements about numbers that you think
of a kind of like gold back nature that
you think well yeah that's something I'd
want to be able to prove it's true and
they showed that these were sentences
which were were true but not provable
within quite a standard system for
mathematics so we've now discovered that
we can't hope that it's just weird
self-referential gazillion sentences
that are going to be knocked out it
could be gold bar it could be go about
twin primes might also be something like
that a girdle even talks about the
Riemann hypothesis we might be having
trouble proving it but just because we
haven't expanded the axioms of
mathematics to such a level that it is
provable
now there are some sentences like
Riemann which are intriguing because it
Riemann turns out to be a mathematical
statement which doesn't have a proof we
could prove that that it doesn't have a
proof weirdly this would prove that the
Riemann hypothesis must be true
now you go all out of why because if the
Riemann hypothesis is false this means
that there's a zero off the line this
means there's actually a constructive
way to find that you can set computer
off and eventually after a finite
process if it's false it will find the
reason why it's false so if it's false
it must be provably false so if we find
that riemann is actually undecidable
cannot be proved from the axioms of
mathematics there's no way it can be
false because that will be provable so
it must be true so this is a really
weird way that you might prove Riemann
hypothesis is to prove that is actually
an undecidable statement within the
axioms of mathematics if you're watching
this video thinking you've got even more
questions about girdling completeness
don't worry so did I and there's a whole
lot of extra interview footage click the
links on the screen or in the video
description also in the video
description you'll find a link to
Professor to sort of--it's recent book
which has a whole bunch of extra stuff
about girdling completeness and other
stuff that science maybe just can't know
to think that you know I think it's
still interesting to explore the things
which might always transcend our
knowledge and of course religion just
gives these things far too many
properties they should never have but I
think that rather abstract idea of the
unknown it is still quite an intriguing
one